[Music]
on today's show we talked to a woman who
is struggling to connect with her
stepdaughter we talk to a retired police
officer who's learning to live a new
life
we talked to a mom who has a
life-altering medical diagnosis with her
child and she wants to know how to
rebuild stay tuned
[Music]
hey
what's up this is john with the dr john
deloney show
hope you're doing well if your family's
healthy hope y'all are taking care of
each other and i hope you are laughing
more than you are
not in this show we talk about mental
health relationships we talk about
everything i'm so glad that you're with
us and i want to start this show off
with a confession
james i'm gonna go ahead and just put it
out there to america
james over the holidays
got the greatest backpack that exists
now listen i'm a philson guy
i just believe in philson bags but then
i've been coveting this bag forever
it's the go rook backpack those guys are
incredible they have i've no spill
affiliate with them whatsoever but
they have some entree leadership ties do
they they create bomb proof stuff
literally and figuratively
and then james showed up here with a
goruck backpack and i got to see it
and then i hit send on the final final
draft of that book and i thought i
should buy myself a hit send gift and so
i want everyone to know
james got the backpack first and i
literally bought the exact one i was
like hey what which one did you get man
and i got the same one there is nothing
lamer than that man it's like hey guys
can i wear your same shirt and shoes so
james i'm sorry it's already listed on
ebay you're already selling yourself
kidding
it's awesome i got to all camo one
though just kidding i didn't i got the
exact everything's the same the chances
of us mixing up backpacks 100 chance
except i'll have like cool patches or i
don't know i might have cool patches but
so anyway i'm a sheep and i just follow
me james everywhere he goes he's the
good i'm the not good
kelly are you gonna get one uh no
let's go to ann in cincinnati what's up
ann how are we doing
hi dr john it's nice to talk to you
today it is nice to talk to you how are
things going
uh going pretty well good good what's up
how can i help
um so i would like to know how to best
be there for my teen stepdaughter
as she works through some relationship
issues with her mom
wow okay so how long have you all been
in each other's life or let me
say that a little less complicated how
long have you been in her life
about 11 years okay so you've been in it
for a while
yeah tell me about it
um so she's 14
and
she's just the best kid ever she really
is
um and
we knew from early on that like her mom
just wasn't very dependable
and so we just kind of took over
everything like we we never depended on
her for anything
um we being you and the 14 year old are
you and your husband my husband and i
okay um yeah because i mean up until a
couple years ago you know she thought
her mom hung the moon and so we never
told her any different
but you know you would see her at
sporting events or school events and
she's watching the door and like just
seeing the anxiety on her face because
her mom's not there or mom's showing up
late you know it just
i knew that this day was going to come
but it just it sucks
um
so
last year
um our daughter came to us and said that
she was depressed and suicidal
so um we got her into a doctor and then
within a few days she was admitted into
inpatient treatment
and it took about
six months of weekly sessions and
violate then bi-weekly sessions for her
to really
no longer be have suicidal thoughts but
then with all of that
came out a lot of the issues that she's
had with her mom
and so
you know we never want to say anything
bad about her but it's hard to be
truthful and
political and then
so all of that kind of came to a head
over the summer it was my daughter's
birthday
and
it was actually like we have 50 50
custody and it was actually her week
with her mom but her mom
my daughter wanted like a special dinner
made for that i make
so i asked her mom can i make dinner for
and then like your family can come over
have dinner with our family and she was
like you know we don't want to come but
you can still do that so like we get
along great we all work well together
um
so
then after my daughter got back to her
house that night
she found out like her mom hadn't done
anything for her for her birthday
so no gift um
like nothing and all she had asked for
was like a 30 video game so then the
next day
it kind of blew up my husband kind of
blew up on her
and you know was asking why she didn't
get her anything for her birthday at all
and she was like well i'm getting
married soon i don't have the money
so
um
it like everything just kind of it got
out in the open then and um so we have a
lot of open conversations with um our
daughter
and you know she's confided in me and a
lot of stuff so
you know i just
i get to where like when she's talking
to me about these things like you know
again like i don't want to say anything
bad about her mom
i don't know where the line is and she
does vent to me quite a bit
so i just i've tried to get better about
just listening and not giving her
any advice at all but i feel like i just
i just don't know what to say
man i appreciate your heart so much
that's awesome
i really do appreci i can imagine you
love this man you love this little girl
and your
instincts are to
like i'll solve this problem you know
what i mean yeah and yeah the restraint
you're showing is just unbelievable it's
it's noble and i'm grateful for you
um
so your instincts are right and even
when it's hard i'll always double back
on don't ever talk bad about mom
there is a difference between
stating facts
and talking bad about mom
so there is a
i can imagine a scenario where it would
feel really good and you'd be justified
to
in a few months be like can you believe
your mom didn't even get you a present
and
have your daughter say i know and you
did and dad did that would feel good it
would feel like you're winning right but
it's not a competition
there's a difference between
when your daughter says hey i wanna i
don't wanna get my hopes up last year
mom didn't get me anything and you going
yeah she she didn't last year she was
having some financial issues and she
didn't get you anything she loves you
though
um that's one way to handle it versus i
know can you believe she just forgot you
right one of those is a fact
and i'm just stating the fact and do you
and i think that's a characteristic yeah
absolutely um but i'm just stating the
facts that's one way to do it right and
i think that's completely okay if you
don't do that your kid will feel like
she's crazy
like she's having this experience with a
woman who's not
saying i love you and not demonstrating
it
and
nobody in her world will acknowledge
that that that makes her feel nuts but
that's different than talking crap about
it right is that fair
yeah and another thing that like so she
had actually
after that happened she had invited her
to one of her counseling sessions
and said like i don't feel seen and i
don't feel heard by you um
you know like we don't do anything
together unless i suggested my daughter
was saying that
so they had this plan in place to do
more you know things together things
that don't cost any money
and um and then her mom just never yeah
that's the cutest thing that's never
gonna happen no absolutely not yeah
and i tried to talk to her about like
well you may just have to grieve you
know like you suggest grief
that's not the mom you have and
she's just she's not ready to give up on
it and it just
it's like knowing your child's gonna
break their arm and just watching it
happen yeah
except it's their mom and so they're
they're they're breaking their soul
right yeah
and especially you want to just rattle
that other adult and say for god's sake
show up to the park what else are you
doing
right this is it i know that she loves
her yeah
well but there does come a point when
i'm gonna say that your actions your
behavior is a language and your actions
are telling me you do not love this kid
you love to say that you love this kid
but you are not demonstrating that
and the the devastating thing for you i
mean i love that analogy i've never
heard it before but i love it
you're watching a car wreck happen
and you know that your daughter is going
to continue to try to solve that gap
that her mom has placed between them
because it's mom's job to make sure that
daughter knows that she's loved and is
valued even if she doesn't live in that
house
and mom is choosing not to do a little
thing like go to a park with a kid or
show up to a game or something like that
right they're choosing that
and
that your daughter is going to continue
to try to solve that
and solve that and solve that so i do
think it's fair to have conversations
like
that's not your responsibility or that's
not your job
she's still gonna do it anyway because
she's 14 and she's trying to figure out
what about her is so unlovable that her
own mom doesn't love her
um but i think it's it's continuing to
lean into that that's not your job it's
not your job and i also think it's real
important to develop this one really
important sentence
thank you so much for sharing that with
me followed by a big hug
okay that phrase
gets you out of having to comment on it
if she asks for your opinion or less
than your opinion
um if she asks for advice then she's
inviting you into this conversation
and even my wife will sometimes ask me
she'll she'll
are you asking for my what i think you
should do in this moment
and when that happens i'm gonna give my
i've been invited in i'm gonna give my
adult wisdom here
because i think that's a honorable thing
to do so for instance she says
hey i i was thinking about inviting mom
to this thing but i don't think she's
gonna show up what do you think i should
do
and you can then say are you asking me
if you should invite your mom to this
thing
yes that's what i'm asking you tell me
about the last three or four times
you've invited her to something
she never shows up she always says she's
going to and she never shows up
what about this time is going to be
different
do you still want to give it a shot
great
yeah i'll support you everyone do so but
you're you're teaching her how to think
through these things without you being
like
hell no don't call her she doesn't get
to hang out with you she always stands
does that make sense
yeah yeah it does and
actually happens
so hard i know that's so hard so hard
isn't it
yeah it really is
um because i am a fixer and but i've
just you know realized that that's not
gonna help her as she gets you know
older and into as being an adult so
it's just it's just it's awful to you
know watch your kids suffer like just
hurt yeah um it is there is a place too
and i i
may get some pushback on that and this
and that's okay i'm not tied to this but
i do think there's a different
conversation dad can have than you can
have
there is some
conversation that he can talk about mom
a little bit
like hey i know your mom stood you up
last night i'm very sorry that shouldn't
have happened
he can have that conversation because
there's not that sense of competition
and betrayal that your daughter feels
between you and her her mom
and so when there's a
sense of deep mourning and someone's got
to say something which i do think that's
important someone's got to speak up
i know you wanted your mom to come to
the game and i'm so sorry she didn't
show up
i like that conversation happening from
dad
yeah because it doesn't look like he's
trying to make a move and be like so i'm
the good mom it doesn't feel like that
you can hug deeply and say i'm so sorry
that you're disappointed
and that's when dad comes in and says
yeah mom should have showed up and i'm
sorry that she didn't
okay right and i know that's fine line
but he can step up and have some of
those conversations but
all that to say is i know this is so
hard i want you to make sure you're
getting your needs met other places
because the restraint you're showing is
going to be exhausting right
yeah and it's frustrating and you want
to just go i'm doing all this work why
won't she recognize it why is she still
sad over this other lady
well yeah and i
when she was younger i did go through
that um
but really just being completely open
and honest with her like with each other
you know um like she has even said like
i know i have you
but it doesn't change the fact that you
know that's my mom and so it's like
they're not mutually exclusive like you
know yes i do have you but i also want
my mom too you know
it's less about well it's it is i want
my mom
but it's more about
i want to know what about me is so
unlovable
yeah and i guess is there a way for us
to
help her yeah because i just i keep
trying to tell her like this has nothing
to do with you because she really
is just such a not a 14 year old who's
just wondering what about me is not
lovable
and she's been diagnosed with
automatic negative thoughts
i don't know if that's a
i haven't heard that diagnosis but it
wouldn't surprise me the dsm is pretty
thick um yeah there's like the body will
protect itself
and the one person who's supposed to
show up in your life regard no matter
what is mom
and hers isn't and she's got dad she's
got an incredible world-class stepmom
but there's that voice inside saying
yeah but your mom doesn't love you
and so lots and lots and lots of
physical touch
holding hands lots of hugs daily hugs
um
possibly having a journal that you all
share together like and you may have
heard me talk about this on the show
a journal between um
like just between two women and it she
puts it on your bed and then you write
in it and put it on her bed and it's
something y'all don't talk about unless
you have like once a month we're gonna
go talk about what's in the journal or
whatever but it's a way to keep a
dialogue open because she's 14 now she's
about to enter into a season where she's
gonna stop communicating with you
and there may even become a point when
her
hurting her pain has to become
somebody's fault not her mom's and it
will have to become your you're about to
enter into a new season is what i'm
saying so starting now with some sort of
communication tool i love the idea of a
journal that y'all share i write in it
you write in it i write in it you write
in it and she can go back and see all of
the positive reinforcement you've put in
this thing how great she is how
wonderful how much you love her what a
great young girl she is um what an
incredible woman she's growing into all
those things you can continue to
reinforce that and when you have
automatically default to negative
thinking you can spin those things out
but when it's written down you go back
and see it again you see it again and
you see it again and that's actually how
you over time begin to shift that
default setting
and so i would recommend y'all do
something like that together lots of
physical touch dad getting involved with
a little bit more conversation and at
some point
at some point
maybe dad or you i don't know y'all's
relationship but somebody has a
conversation with mom that says stop
saying you're going to show up and then
showing up you're breaking this girl's
heart
it's just too much for her
it's stopped breaking the girl's heart
just have the courage to say i'm not
coming
i don't want to be a part of your life
don't continue to dangle your
relationship your love out there like a
carrot and this 14 year old's gonna
chase it and chase it she's gonna chase
it the rest of her life thanks for
loving ann you're awesome be right back
on the dr john de luna show
do you want a better life a better
marriage better mental and physical
health the single most important action
you can take to improve your mental and
physical health to change your entire
life is to get enough deep restorative
quality sleep i know this from research
and as a guy who has struggled with
sleep for my entire life
and for me good sleep starts with a
world-class mattress that's why my
family sleeps on dream cloud mattress
dream cloud is advanced technology and
you can buy it in the store or you can
do it like i did and have it shipped
directly to your house dreamcloud is
running their biggest offer ever
exclusively for dr john daloni show
listeners 399 bucks and accessories plus
an additional 250 discount that's a
total of
649 dollars in accessories and savings
pillows mattress protectors luxury
sheets all of it it's time to stop
sleeping on your old college mattress or
the old hand-me-down from grandma and
start changing your life visit
dreamcloudsleep.com or
sleep and enter promo code deloney and
get your new mattress today
all right we are back let's go to steve
in grand junction colorado what's up
steve
hey john how's it going man good brother
hey you all do okay with the fires and
everything
well we're on the other side of the
state so we avoided it but that was uh
that was something else that was gnarly
man what a devastating mess that was
yeah we had the opposite problem we had
10 feet of snow
that same week in the mountains right
here next to us so
it's pretty bizarre that's so crazy
oh my gosh all right so what's up dude
how can i help man
hey so um
i'm a retired cop um
i did it for seven years i say retired
because
it's a lifetime of experiences and
sorrow that you yeah you know
experienced in that amount of time
um what do you do now
i'm self-employed now um my wife and i
own
three businesses because we're
serial entrepreneurs
and uh sick like that i guess are y'all
making any money
what's that y'all making any money
we are yeah good
yeah
so it's a good fit um
so we've kind of hit a point here where
um things are starting to calm down a
little bit and i can think and i've been
able to hire some people so i'm not
having to do it all
and um
voices are coming huh
what's that are the voices coming
well it's more like um i'm a little
concerned that
there's some things that maybe didn't
deal with yeah um as a cop and uh
we've got four kids together
the oldest is 13 the youngest is six
and i'm just a little worried that
i don't know i guess i'm starting to
wake up to the fact that there's some
things like i don't know what i don't
know yeah and uh so that's i guess the
reason for my call is i was hoping you
could maybe
um give me a few pointers i know um
you have a little bit of experience with
this i do yeah and um
yeah so well man thanks for your bravery
man thanks for your service thanks for
bravery and thanks for having the
courage just to to reach out yeah i grew
up in the home of a homicide detective
and a swat guy i grew up i was your kid
and i've also
run the streets with cops for several
years and
yes i caught my some of that stuff
leaking out onto my kids too and so yeah
absolutely um
when you say i haven't dealt with some
stuff tell me about what you're thinking
about
well
i mean you know there's a lot of just
you just go from call to call and you
don't really get to pause and deal with
it
um and you just wake up and do it again
the next day
yeah so
i want to stop right there so people who
don't know
most people have no idea as to how many
calls a police officer takes in a given
night
and you go from
noise complaint that
maybe someone's going to shoot somebody
to
dealing with a you know a 1016 like
there's a domestic somebody just beat up
their girlfriend and you got to get in
the middle of that and you may have to
arrest somebody you may not then you get
back in your car and then you go deal
with the 1087 there's a dead body here
somebody had a heart attack and they're
there but you got to make sure there's
no foul play and then you get in the car
and you go to like you just do that for
the whole shift
right yeah and then you go home yeah and
you
get up the next day and you get back in
the car and then you go straight to a
car wreck and then to another domestic
and then to another domestic and then to
that just never stops
never ever ever stops and by the way you
should go lyft too go work out and uh
make sure you get your dry cleaning done
like it just never quits
is there anything that's uh an excuse
this language is there anything that's
leaking out in your behavior or the way
you're treating your kids or your wife
that you think that man that doesn't
feel right
um
i think i just noticed things like you
know i can't like i'm having a harder
time just like sitting and playing with
my kids okay my patience is lower
um
you know you get pretty used to
squashing the motion yes
you go see one thing and then and for
whatever reason when i was doing it it
wasn't that bad i
i felt like i dealt with it i did
went to the gym i did a lot of mixed
martial arts um
i didn't drink couldn't
you know i knew i kind of knew what some
of the unhealthy behavior was and how to
deal with it but for whatever reason
now it's it's um more difficult i guess
you know you don't have the
the support of the guys that you work
with yep um
and um who is yours who who do you go
hang out with and just grab a drink with
or who do you go hang out with do you
have guy buddies that you guys spend
time
yeah i've got friends they're more like
in the
they're outside of that realm yep i
don't really understand it yep
and those guys were still living it
working the night shift
it's uh it's nine o'clock here and i
just watched a friend of mine drive down
my road getting off the night shift yeah
yeah and is there a part of you that
misses it
i do i miss it and i didn't run the beat
like you did i miss it
yeah i missed the adrenaline there you
go i love the action
so um a traumatized brain and without
it's important to note a couple things
trauma is
um
trauma's acute and you know that right
you show up and somebody's you're with
somebody doing cpr on them as they
breathe their last breaths that's
traumatic right your body
has a trauma response there or you're in
the middle of a fist fight and you draw
your weapon and like that
that is you're trying to protect
somebody
that's trauma
there's also
secondary trauma vicarious trauma
whatever you want to call it there's
just something about rolling up on scene
after scene after scene after scene that
we often don't know that trauma's
cumulative
it is a weight so think of it you may
have heard me say think of it like
you've got a backpack on and you're
carrying bricks and at some point
whether they're little pebbles or
they're bricks that weight's the same
and at some point you've got to do the
hard work of letting these things go
here's what i've seen with police
officers specifically over time
one is they have an adjusted bell curve
meaning there is a part of them that is
always looking for
what's about to happen
because police show up in situations
that nobody ever falls off drives off
that road right there except
that's your call and you it only happens
four times a year you get called all
four times so in your head has
identified that curve as a place to die
and you may not realize it that every
time you drive up your body begins to
tense up because it knows people die
right there and the rest of us would
just drive right by that thing we
wouldn't know same with
fist fights same with talking trash same
with a noise violation the last five
noise violations you showed up to ended
up in somebody getting arrested because
they were throwing
they were throwing punches or pulled out
a gun or whatever your body's detection
and i've told this on the show i think
i remember being a young kid and i
showed up to my house with my dad and we
had gone to baseball practice in our
little suburban neighborhood
and
i'd left the back door open
and i'll never forget he pulled his gun
out and cleared the house
and i remember being a young child going
that's probably a little bit much
you know i'm like i remember thinking
yes
that's all yeah i've done that before i
know you haven't i know you and that's
what happens yes and i still i i do a
lock check
two times sometimes three times at my
house i just make the rounds over and
over and over because i know people walk
by and they're not gonna break into your
house but if the doors open they may
just come in right so i know that
and also my wife's like go to bed we
live in the woods like if they're out
here they're gonna kill us anyway
haven't you seen any horror movies it's
going to happen you know i mean
so
yeah um here here's another thing i see
a lot is what i call overreacting
is
like something small happens and my body
has kind of lost the ability
to toggle down to an appropriate
response my all my responses become big
is that fair
does that happen yep okay and then the
third one is a loss of patience i can't
be still
and i can't listen for a long period of
time i just want to get on to the next
thing and i want to go solve this okay
cool i can't do legos one if i play baby
dolls one more time i'm gonna set this
all the dolls on fire it's that it just
it feels like something's well enough
inside of you right is that fair
yeah
so that's a that to me is a is at least
i'm not gonna diagnose anything that to
me is a breadcrumb trail towards a brain
that is on fire
that's just still running and running
and running and the cool thing is
is what you have to do is
the cool thing is you can learn to a
feel safe in your body
b
live a life where your body is not
pumping adrenaline and cortisol through
it 24 7 365 and you have to understand
that's a drug that you're addicted to i
am too
i love it it feels good
and if i don't have it naturally if i
don't have it in my job if i'm not
running the streets with cops and doing
i will create it in other places i will
procrastinate up until the last possible
minute and get it all done because then
i get that rush or i will
kind of respond to a way a little bit
more and then i get that rush or you
know what i mean i'll create it in
stupid places that have no my wife's
like what are you doing that's not even
like this is even a thing right so yeah
it's understanding hey i'm gonna go talk
to somebody have you ever done that
uh
i don't
it's it's i don't you know i don't talk
to a lot of people about it because i
don't think most people understand
and if you say something a little off
color or
really too honest about something
i've noticed it shocks people it does it
does um
so i really haven't because i i guess
maybe i've been a little lazy on it i
just i don't know who that would be
i mean i've gone to a therapist a couple
different times um
what'd you go i was
what's that why'd you go
uh first couple times were just uh like
marriage maintenance um
good for you we we got into a shooting
and they made us talk to a dude um
after that and that was totally useless
yeah um the last thing i'm going to do
is
talk to that guy of course my
chief is you know they're like
psychologically evaluating you to see if
you're going to like go off the rails
right
like this is an honest
thing so
yeah um
not really no
well and you're i mean yeah you're not
going to say something that's going to
get you taken off the beat and so
everybody smiles and says i'm doing
great it's all good i'm sleeping well my
wife's great i love my kids merry
christmas you can statue of liberty and
then they send you out yeah you can tell
it's just a check box for that's for
them that's right um i have i do have a
guy in my life that was
incredible but they had the the police
department had worked out a system to
where he was off out of the system and
so people could be honest with him and
it was it was it was pretty remarkable
um so here's here's a couple things i
want you to start doing
i want you to get
just go to the store dude buy a cheap
old one or you can buy a nice one i just
finally spent the money bought a nice
one for myself this year because i'm
gonna do some hard work this year i'm
doing the same thing you're doing except
you're do your your experience is going
to be way more make more challenge
because i didn't run the beat for seven
straight years okay so i'm not trying to
compare my experience to you i know
that i've got to deal with some stuff
that i saw i got to deal with some stuff
that i was a part of i got to deal with
that and
so what i'm going to start doing is
writing those stories down i actually
have got a story journal i put it right
by my bed i know the phrase story
journal makes most people roll their
eyes especially cops
freaking kidding me a story journal what
are we like in middle school again yes
and here's all i'm doing
a couple of nights ago i wrote in this
thing
you are not a bad father
and for some reason that popped into my
head
is my brain looking for negative things
you could have responded to that
differently you didn't do it bad let's
do it better next time that's me just
writing these things down and what i'm
doing is i'm teaching my body that we
are not going to carry this stuff i'm
going to set it down that when you hear
me say you set the bricks down that's
this that's the beginning stages there
okay and then there's going to be some
and i've heard you say that before and
i've um what do you what do you do with
this journal like you read it again
well yeah occasionally i'll go back
through it and it's cool to see the
journey and it's cool to see oh gosh i'm
still hanging on to this story
still
what a i got to go talk to somebody and
say i keep thinking that i'm a terrible
dad
or some of it's i tell my wife dude this
has popped up five times in a row
like do you like me and she'll just say
yes i do like you john and then i could
say okay i'll write it down i asked my
wife she said she likes me there's
something kinetic about the writing
experience and about getting it outside
of your body
and uh but
so think less about the utility of it
that's a very police officer response
what are we gonna do with it now think
more about it i'm just going to do it
i'm just going to get this thing done
and um i'm going to be as gentle as i
can with the story because i know
there's all kinds of listeners here
i had an experience with a police
officer we had to clean up a scene
before a mom got home to see something
that no mother should ever ever see
yeah and we were by the time that
situation was over
i was laughing so hard i couldn't i
almost threw up
i somebody had turned into one thing to
another to another
and i remember thinking if somebody's
videoing this i'm going to get
institutionalized and i talked i talked
to somebody about it and they said no
that kind of dark humor like your brain
goes to places to protect you
and so there's also a camaraderie you
miss and that's what i don't like about
when whenever they post some police
transcripts some police officers are
garbage you know that um there's some
bad dudes out there that are idiots and
or morons and there's there's a number
of them
but also you can take things way out of
context and not understand what people
were doing at that time
right and you will have to process that
because there was a season i thought i
was a terrible human and then no i don't
at all i know that's part of it right i
even talked to my dad about it who did
homicide for 20 years and he's like no
man you've got to protect yourself and
laughter is a great way to protect your
brain and protect your heart protect
your soul and if people see you doing
that they're gonna think you're an evil
awful you're gonna have to process all
of those things right the jokes the
things you saw the scenes you had to
clean up the moms you had to hug all of
those things over time make their way
out and not not every single story but
over time those things come and they
come and they come but it's about you
remembering them writing them down and
here's what you're doing with your brain
you are letting your brain know
at one time we were in a situation we
weren't safe
we're safe now
and your brain will go oh okay and it
will slowly start to go huh
relax relax the second thing you have to
have to have to do is have somebody to
talk to whether that's a counselor
whether that's a group of guys that you
meet with whether that's a group of
people who are still cops and you meet
with them and you you be the guy that
say all right how's everybody's marriage
doing
how's everybody taking care of
themselves what's the hardest thing you
all saw this week
what's the most annoying and you be the
guy that leads that group of guys into
talking because you can because you're
not in the system anymore
that would be a gift to you that would
be a gift to them and it will be a gift
to your entire community to have a group
of police officers who are well
and i know i'm i'm talking about
unicorns and rainbows right now but dude
if you set that up it could be powerful
because i've seen it i've been a part of
a police department where
they had that kind of discussion and it
was incredible it was magic man it was
really great yeah
yeah
but you're gonna have to get connected
and you're gonna have to start writing
stuff down
and then one man once you get down that
road when you get connected then you get
into all kind of the body work and
um i mean you can see the navy seals
guys who are doing meditation and
yoga and the guys who start running i
mean there's all kinds of ways to
process this trauma cold tubs
all kinds of ways to process the trauma
but it starts with connection and it
starts with um
writing stuff down
seeing where i'm at
it's deciding i'm going to go play for
30 minutes with my kid i'm going to do
30 minutes i can do 30 minutes and i'm
going to be all in i'm going to put my
phone away i'm going to have a watch and
i'm gonna set it and i'm gonna be
lasered in on these little dolls that
we're playing with
or i'm gonna go kick a soccer ball for
30 minutes with my kid i'm gonna do it
no matter what if i get bored i'm gonna
lean into the boredom if i get
frustrated i'm gonna lean into the
frustration
when i get frustrated i will have a
signal that i will pre-determine with my
wife and we will say
i'm frustrated i need to take a walk and
then i'll be back and she's gonna know
i'm gonna know and then i'm gonna come
back and i'm not gonna yell i'm not
going to get angry i'm going to be calm
i'm going to be that that's practicing
leaning into a life that's not full of
adrenaline cortisol all the time
it's practice it's practice
but i think every police officer should
have a good trauma counselor that they
talk to that says hey i saw some stuff
some people are affected in different
ways in other ways and
it's short-term long-term all that stuff
every everybody does trauma different
but i want you know you're not alone i'm
proud of you god i'm proud of you man i
wish every police officer would take the
inventory on their lives that you're
taking on yours i'm grateful for you my
brother for your time and your service
and for caring about your family it's so
good
gentlemen talk
about it to other people write it down
talk about it write it down be right
back on the dr john luna show
one of the most common questions folks
ask me is what they should do when
anxiety or panic strikes like a
lightning bolt i've been helping folks
101 for years but i wanted to create
something that everyone could use
anywhere at any time so i created a free
guided meditation it's not really a
meditation but really me just walking
with you through your anxiety alarms
from start to finish i'll guide you
through a breathing exercise and show
you how to lean in listen and head
towards healing it is free and it's for
everyone you can download this guided
meditation today for free at
johndaloni.com
all right we are back let's take one
more let's go to chrissy and alabama oh
it's sad in alabama today how are you
chrissy
i'm doing well how are you good have you
recovered
uh is this a sports reference
oh you're the best
you're the best it's literally a
national day of mourning in alabama last
night when we're recording this was the
alabama georgia game which georgia
demolished alabama and i love that you
don't even know what i'm talking about
christy
i mean
you're the best the best so good is this
a sports reference oh you're awesome all
right so what's up
all right um okay so my son um who's
about to be eight was just diagnosed
with a condition called pandas which
stands for oh the audio
pediatric yeah pediatric autoimmune
neuro psychiatric disorder from stress
yeah tell me about that
um
it's horrible yeah
what's he have does he have ocd or ticks
or
like what's up
and ticks
it went from he was sick with strep in
november
and
it almost felt like overnight after he
finished like his
you know five days of antibiotics
um he became my like sweet gentle
outdoor loving
great imagination little boy turned into
this
ocd
raging
um almost manic yeah
defiance i mean i mean like it was like
looking at a stranger
what a terrifying thing for your mom as
a mom
yes terrifying and he i mean he would go
into these fits for hours like just
non-stop rage for hours yeah yeah and my
you know my husband and i and we have a
four-year-old and we were all just like
what is happening
so what what how'd y'all go through the
process to get that diagnostic because i
know it's a it's a rare thing but you
sometimes people have to go through
multiple people to get diagnosed there
yes we were actually extremely lucky
because
um
the principal from my kid's school
that i cuz he was struggling
at school and there everybody was like
he just seemed so different what's going
on and i said you know he hasn't really
been himself since he had stress
and the principal said have you ever
heard of pandas and i didn't end what a
great principle wow awesome so amazing
and then she and so i went into like
crazy research mode
and then we ended up finding out that
there was a
pediatrician
um in the town just down the way from us
um who
whose son had it and and he like is a
you know he he knows about it he knows
how to treat it
um and he's actually opened up his own
practice um just dealing with more
complex cases because
the appointments need to be longer than
the 10-minute pediatrician appointment
that's exactly right yeah you work
through it and so we were super lucky
because we've been able to start
treatment where
i have now joined some facebook groups
of like
for this and there are some people who
you know for years
they didn't have an official diagnosis
geez and then did they just
it's like low dose steroids and and
antibiotics right
yep yes so we're on the steroids and the
antibiotic we're on our second month of
antibiotics in our first month of
steroids and
we're a day
four into the steroids and we've it's
already like we're seeing
chunks of our child come back to us
that's so awesome
so good man that makes my heart feel
good i've heard and again i've got no
dirt no direct experience to this at all
but i've heard that you can
it's like a light switch on and then it
i mean off and then it comes back on
that with yeah with the right um the
right lot of steroids and antibiotics
and what like obviously you have to be
working with a doctor to get into this
kind of stuff but that it can be magic
dark magic
into this thing and incredible magic on
the way out of this thing
yeah and then just doing a lot of
lifestyle changes of just
continuing to like vitamin d a lot of
these kids are real vitamin d low and
just so
um i think every kid's vitamin d low
these days but so unfortunately yeah
one high five to you i'm glad you all
figured this out
big time shout out to your principal
who's just calling it out having a
doctor in your community that's so great
and you acted on it quick
um how can i help
um well i've heard you i listen to your
show all the time and i hear you talk
about nobody does that's so good yeah
i know i'm one of the 17.
um but like your your analogy with like
the 911 like rebuilding
um after
because he's coming back but like so
much of our life is
is just like a everything has changed
yes um
and you know he we have to be extremely
he's very immune compromised until we
can get him really healthy and well and
his gut healthy and his the inflammation
from his brain down so
we've ended up pulling him from school
because he just he can't risk getting
covet or flu or even just strep or cold
like anything will set him back because
his body is so
fragile right now can i just ask you one
quick question
you just mentioned gut health and
is is that in response to the
antibiotics
um no so they're finding the connection
between like the gut minds
the gut brain connection i i just need
you to know that as as
that makes my heart feel so good
you are on the right path
the fact that you know even know about
that
puts you so in rare air and makes my
heart feel good the the antibiotics will
wreak havoc on the gut biome and having
a doctor who's working with you on
making sure that that stays healthy
oh my gosh your kid's gonna be great
chrissy's gonna be great
god lee what a that's a such a beautiful
story okay i interrupted you but yeah so
he's immunocompromised right he's got a
lot going on his br his yeah for those
of you listening
we could we could get off into the rails
on this thing but my understanding which
is limited is that strep is such an
ancient virus it is it's great at
mimicking it's great at hiding in the
body
and that it mimics other healthy cells
and at some point in rare cases the your
body will turn on
thinking that oh there it is it's hiding
and then it mows down a whole bunch of
good stuff
and
then all of a sudden your brain gets
super over inflamed and it just changes
your personality your response it just
goes haywire is that is that right yeah
okay yes yeah exactly okay um and so now
and then you know we have the added
uh
that uh i don't know what you would call
it but he's losing teeth now um and
every time that he a two starts to
wiggle that germs in his body and then
his body again attacks
that causing more inflammation so now
every time
so he literally had strep and then like
a week later he lost a tooth and then
like a week later it lasted too so he
gets these what they call flares so all
of a sudden we'll be like
like we think we're doing really well
and then all of a sudden he's like
raging again and we're like what in the
world and then we like i'm like open
your mouth let me see and i'm like oh
wiggly too
but it's just going you know it's just
germs right up into the
blood brain barrier and all this stuff
so
um but yes it's basically so he you know
so the
you know we've had to pull him from
school
um
we actually just pulled his little
brother from school because you know if
he's at school with jeremy kids then you
know we just need to
do that and we're
is the doctor
is the doctor recommending this that you
pull the kids out
yeah well they were saying that um so
much of it some of the main some of the
symptoms which is so strange um is like
school refusal like just the
there's so much going on at school and
their brains just are so inflamed that
they can't
even handle like a stimulation from
school yeah okay so a lot of they can
develop like sensory issues and stuff
and kicks from that yep yep
all right so
i'm gonna give you good stuff and then
the hard stuff you ready
okay i'm ready so
if this is the first major
trauma with your kids
i'm assuming it is is that fair
um yes okay
um
you you're
looking to
this idea that our family is now
different
is
incredible
chrissy i don't know
i
i don't know
what
where you come from
in there in alabama but you are
you are so far ahead of the curve you're
an inspiring woman it's awesome
your kids are so lucky to have you
understanding okay we're all different
now because we stared over the edge of
the cliff
and we realized oh gosh our kid could
just get a little bit of sickness and
then just be gone
and that most parents don't ever
experience that until it happens
it's terrifying everything's different
now
and
um then that turns into what about this
what about this and that's where you got
to be really careful and here's where i
want to
challenge you to not keep picking up the
flag pole and moving it inch by inch i
want you to pick it up and go excavate
the whole site
right that who we were is over we're new
now we're going to build something new
but we're going to we're going to plant
the flag way over there and say this is
who we're going to be here's what i'm
talking about
it can be
your
determination to make sure your kid's
okay
can quickly turn into him being
terrified of his own body
yep because mom is always saying what
about this what about this and oh my
gosh what about that we gotta pull you
out of this we gotta take care of that
and if that's what the doctor's calling
for great
my one i love facebook groups because
they allow people who have strange
things like that most neighbor nope
nobody in your circle has
kids with this right
so
you get instant community
and also
you get all of the one in a trillion
things
yeah and it turns you into a paranoid
maniac right
are you there yet
um no i'm i am self-aware enough to know
like uh so i've started to like i've
started to eat like when it first
started happening
like in december we were just kind of
like what is happening and i did a lot
you know i did my research and now
i'm starting to step back more and being
like
i have
the plan you know and so i've started to
like you know i'm reading books before
bed instead of like i'm implementing
good
boundaries of things and just being like
turn it off
every and every case is different so if
i'm reading that this one person had a
13 year struggle with this that's not
going to help me right now yeah yes yes
you continue to amaze me yes turn it all
off you've got the info you need you got
a great doctor
let's be done with to inputting new
information there's not going to be a an
article on google you stumble onto and
you go no i'll try this it's just going
to be another
facebook
person being like oh yeah well i found
it in the vacuum and you're gonna be
like oh okay let's burn the vacuum it's
it's never gonna stop right it's 5g it's
because of the oh my gosh what whatever
it is
and yeah
absolutely take it off so you're there a
key to when you when you decide we're
going to excavate and build something
new
key number one is having somebody do it
with you is your husband in with you
good guy yes oh yeah okay well he won
the lottery marrying you and hopefully
it's reciprocal hopefully you won the
lottery marrying him
you all decide we're gonna take care of
our marriage
and our bodies
you have to do that when a kid gets sick
the first thing that goes out the window
is intimacy
the second thing that goes out the
window is
treating each other with kindness
the third thing that goes out is our
budget the fourth just these stable um
intentional ways of doing life go out
the door because everything's on fire
yep and now you said it and i'm gonna
use your own words it's not on fire
anymore now you can just read books
before bed
is that you know what you hear i'm going
now you can start redoing life again
and you're gonna feel guilty for doing a
lot that that's gonna be the key here
and then deciding what do we want this
thing to look like so we got a kid who's
got a rare thing we're gonna keep
trusting the doctors on this
and we're gonna keep doing the right
things there and we're gonna watch a
movie because movies are fun
and we are going to oh we can't play
basketball anymore cool we're going to
get a foosball table we're gonna have to
deliver to the house we're gonna play
foosball because that's gonna be fun
we're gonna we're gonna find joy
in whatever
context whatever ecosystem makes sense
for joy for us but we're not going to
live a joyful life
yeah and we're gonna grieve the absolute
hell out of this thing because it sucks
yeah
right
have you done that yet have you had a
moment where you're just by yourself and
you or with the girlfriend and you just
broke the crap down
yeah um i was super lucky that my mom
was able to fly
uh we're military so we're down here
without family and stuff and my mom when
it was first happening i was like
something is happening mom and like you
need to come down here
um and
we her and i were able to kind of get
away and just um
i don't know i just cried and she's just
i was able to just vent and cry and be
mad good good good and just like
scream my husband and i even thought
maybe we could invest in a um like a
punching bag we can maybe have in the
garage
uh so i would invest that's fine i have
one in my garage i would invest in
a
uh journal and i know it's so lame i
would write this stuff down so that you
have the story to tell your son in five
years and 10 years and 20 years
and that you're gonna tell his future
spouse someday you're going to write
this down and you're going to tell the
story
um and make sure that all the feelings
all of the the ups and the downs today
was a great day today was an awful day i
cried all day i'm so sorry that you're
going through this i hate you're not in
school i want him to see that stuff and
i want that crap out of your body onto
the paper yeah
and we've been talking i mean he can
tell when it when he's like he has said
like something is wrong with me there's
something in my brain like he's aware
yeah that these changes are happening he
when he goes under the rages he doesn't
remember them
um which i guess is a blessing because
of some of the horrific things he's
he has said
when it first happened
i mean we remember yeah well and again
you're gonna have to work really hard
and when i say work really hard you're
gonna have to be honest with your
husband he's got to be honest with you
you're gonna have to write stuff down
and get a counselor if you need one but
you're gonna have to know he was eight
and he's he's having a brain disorder
right now
and so when he says i hate you or you
fill in the blank
that's not personal even though god it
feels personal it's like it's like
poltergeist right
yeah and my uh father uh was bipolar and
committed well he died from suicide um
when i was 18 and we are i'm seeing that
a lot of this is triggering yes
um yes i will have to go back to emdr uh
therapy eventually so your body's got a
trauma response but it here's the thing
yeah you
that even makes more sense but i know
it's different but i know it's different
it's different but our bodies they'll
say oh we remember when we were out of
control
we remember the terror we remember the
fear we've got a system for let's let's
run the program
and you've also done a lot of work to
heal from your dad's passing
and
those same skills will come into play
here as you practice a new life
but yeah if you've been down that road
before and you know yourself think yeah
go call a trauma counselor do it today
call somebody and just say i need to
just go vomit up here
i've been through trauma before i've
been through it hard i thought i was
gonna i lost my dad i thought i was
about to lose my son
or i thought
he's gonna be with us and be gone and i
would have lost him in in spirit but not
in body oh that is so terrifying so
terrifying yes go talk to somebody
and if you need to get punched back get
a punching bag but also get a journal
and write these things down keep these
things as a story be super honest and
open get a group get people to
that you can have in your life
just to go
yeah
and get off the internets i'm so proud
of you god i'm so proud of you you're
amazing chrissy you're amazing
man
in fact you don't got biomass and you
decided to self get off of the internet
so great
find ways go on a date with your husband
go on a date
get a babysitter and go on a date figure
out how to do that
or it may be that put a kid a video on
for the kids in one room and you'll go
close the door and you'll have a date
like make sure y'all are staying plugged
in with each other that calms your brain
down
it let your brain know
i wasn't safe but now i am i'm okay
so proud of you give me a call let me
know how he's doing i really want to
know cause i'm gonna guess he's gonna be
up and running around in the next month
or two and i want to
hear that story and we'll tell everybody
who's listening thank you so so much for
your call chrissy as we wrap up today's
show
robert smith and the boys this one's
picked by james great song it's one of
the greatest songs of all time it's by
the cure the song's called pictures of
you and it goes like this
i've been looking so i love this song
man i've been looking so long at these
pictures of you that i almost believe
they're real
i've been living so long with my
pictures of you that i almost believe
that the pictures are all i can feel
remembering you standing quiet in the
rain as i ran to your heart to be near
and we kissed as the sky fell
in holding you close how i always held
you close in your fear remembering you
running soft through the night you were
bigger and brighter and whiter than snow
and screamed at the make-believe
screamed at the sky and you finally
found all your courage to let it all
go
god i love talking to courageous people
like chrissy right here on the dr john
alone show